hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become I'm Joanna so and welcome back
to another crazy workout challenge this
time we're doing 500 app challenge and
guess what there will not be any
crunches okay so there will be a total
of ten exercises we want to complete 25
repetitions per workout and we want to
repeat all the workouts two rounds
through so trust me your apps will be on
fire at the end of this workout right
let's start in a high plank position
the first ab exercise would be cross
climber so start in a high plank and I
want you to maintain this solid plank
and cross your right knee over to your
left elbow okay
so left and right is one good and
because we are doing 500 ab exercise I
want you to just pace a breathing take
any own pace and focus on proper form so
do not Pike your butt too high or dip
your hips good keep going so right knee
to left elbow and left knee to the right
elbow and just gaze gently on the floor
nice crossover work on your lower abs
your upper abs as well as your Bleek's
good keep going make sure you're
breathing five four last three three
last two last one and now down onto the
mat we're going to work on knee tucks
okay so gently support your body support
your upper body
place your pumps on the floor and just
give me knee tucks tuck your knee in
extended and in good so drive your knees
close to your chest keep going
crunch it in point it out crunch and
point and just relax your shoulders okay
you will really feel to work on your
Appa as well as your lower abs keep
going breathe in breathe out five four
three two one okay turn over back onto
plank
spider-man okay so left and right will
be - I'm going to have mercy on you okay
so point your knees out touch your
elbows aim to drive your knee close your
elbows and this will be working on your
obliques good keep going maintain a high
plank position and keep crunching to the
sides nice ten more plus six more plus
four plus two and last one right back
into this position next Russian twist so
you have an option choose to place both
heels down on the floor and twist left
and right okay beginners you can start
this way twist point or if you want to
challenge yourself and lift both heels
off the floor and keep twisting so bend
your knees a little bit good keep going
left and right is one last ten nine
eight seven six five four three two and
last one more and shake it out now let's
get back into plank position
bury Jack's okay so what are we to do is
start in a narrow plank jump out as you
jump in crunch your knees in okay so
let's go for 25 keep going
three take your knees in bend your knees
bring it close to the floor
and remember to gaze down on the floor
and breathe keep going five four three
last two last one all right shake it out
a little bit back onto your bun flutter
kicks okay so now he'll lie straight
down to the floor again if you want to
you can support both hands just under
your butt or your lower back and give me
25 flutter kicks okay left and right is
one keep going small flutter kicks lift
both heels of the floor do not rest them
on the floor okay good keep going last
three two one and down now come back up
and give me reverse plank okay so start
with your pumps pointer forward and lift
your butt off the floor okay this is
your starting position dip down and push
it back at 25 and as you come up squeeze
on your abs and your glutes keep going
down and up the weight should be on your
heels all right down push it up look up
and squeeze your glutes your hamstrings
as well as your abs tighten the core
muscles up keep going down and up
last ten nine eight push it up
seven six five four three two one
okay now lie straight down next workout
straight alternating legs okay so what I
want to do is lift one leg up and
alternate good
so rest the heels on the floor bring it
as high up as you can straighten your
legs feel the stretch and hamstring and
the crunch on your lower abs good keep
going good lift your shoulders off the
floor slightly and feel the crunch on
your upper abs okay good bring it up
control it down do not just let your
legs fall straight down keep going guys
you're doing a good job
ten more last eight more seven six five
four three last two more two last one
one all right good job come back up
plank hip dips
okay so again into a plank position and
just dip your hip from the left to the
right okay almost close to the floor
keep going
maintaining a flat back position
nice so again gaze down the kid do not
look straight ahead keep your neck in a
neutral position left and right left and
right
last ten nine eight
can we keep going guys seven six five
that's four three two one more one and
one more last workout okay I am sweating
so back lie back down onto the floor
half wiper so I went to place both arms
spread it out to your side lift both
legs off the floor bend your knees in
the 90 degree position drop them to the
left and up to the right okay so left
and right will be one okay so drop it
left the right one four five good keep
going six seven so this is working the
obliques pull it back up eight drive it
use your hips
use your core to pull your legs back
into the centre nine ten good you got 15
more this is your final workout for the
first round one
let's go two down three as you progress
what you can do is straighten your legs
for five nice ten more six drop it to
the side drive it up drive it up fast
seven drive it up good
eight
nine ten last five more let's go one up
two up last three three last two up one
more down and up
alright get back up that was round one
so you have done 250 repetitions take a
one-minute break
all right you guys ready second round
okay let's do this
so the first workout will be cross
climber start in a high plank position
right to left
okay cross over let's go keep pointing
so working on your abs it's not just
about crunches you can do lots of
different ab workouts which does not
involve crunches so cross your right
knee over to your left elbow and
vice-versa nice keep going that's four
more oops
let's go last five more that's four more
three two one and rest it out okay
straight down onto the floor knee tucks
okay so place both palms on the ground
just support the upper body point your
leg straight drive your knees into your
chest good nice and easy point it out
and drive it in relax the shoulders work
on your lower as well as your upper abs
that's ten more nine eight seven six
five four three two one okay back up
spider-men
alright so left and right will be two
okay so now we want to work on your
obliques up into a plank position
point your knees out this time so point
it out again
drive it to your elbows put it out drive
it as close to your elbows as possible
and remember to inhale exhale breathe in
and out
ten more last eight six last four last
two and good tell over Russian twist
okay still working on your obliques okay
so choose your object you can lift both
hues of the floor and just tap onto the
ground good keep going
twist rotate your upper body feel your
obliques working a pen twist bend your
knees slightly heels off the floor not
too high up just feel interest of the
for ten more eight seven six five four
three two one
okay good Barry jackster get back into
plank position so start in a white plank
position all right hop in bend your
knees and hop back out drive a knees
close to the floor crunch your lower abs
as you hop in and this will bring your
heart rate up so this is a little cardio
workout to help you burn belly fat try
both knees in Bennet and out
keep going you go five more four three
two one all right Oh breathe if you need
to relax
back it down onto the floor flutter
kicks to work on your lower abs okay
get back down choose your option you can
place both hands under your butt adjust
to support your lower back lift your
legs off the floor and go small flutter
kicks suck your belly in and get your
lower abs feel eight ten nine eight
seven six five four three two one oh oh
my god it's burning all right now get
back up into reverse plank okay so pumps
fingers point it forward stay on your
heels push your butt up lower it down up
lower it back down and up good so you
should feel your hamstrings as well as
the glutes working together with your
core as you drive it back up so you
imagine that's a string pulling you up
loosening your body and pulling you back
up down and up stay on the fuse and up
good so if you want to look straight
ahead or look up at the ceiling up down
up squeeze right at the top squeeze last
ten nine squeeze eight seven six squeeze
five relaxer sugar four three two last
one more one okay lie back down all
right
straight alternating legs okay so left
and right again will be two ready
straight arms above let's go crunch up
tap down up and down
both hands in between your legs okay
good crunch extend your legs straight
aim to point your toes up keeping your
legs both straight stretching on your
hamstrings as well as crunching on your
lower abs keep going up last ten eight
more last six
you got this last four that's two and
one more just relax
shake it out a little bit back out into
plank hip dips okay so get into a plank
position a low plank position okay so
stay low drop your hips to the left and
to the right okay
driving as low as you can
you should feel along your hips as well
as the obliques keep going
last time
six more plus five
that's - whoa I can through the burn
just one last workout okay
like back down onto the floor half wiper
okay back down low to the floor all
right so I'm spread out to your sides
okay lift your knees up bend your knees
in a 90 degree position drop it drive it
up and to the right side drive it back
up left and up good this is your final
workout 25 repetitions left and right
will be one okay so take it easy you
have 20 more to go
okay keep going breathe in
breathe in
you have 15 more to go guys
come on stay with me okay stay with me
bend your knees drive it up drive it up
last 10 more good eight more breathe in
and breathe out
you have lost five more five four drive
it push your hands onto the floor last
three last two one more one and to the
other side and up alright just lie down
stretch it out relax for a little while
shake it off you need to just stretch
your body extend lengthen it stretch
your abs stretch your lower back
stretch your arms as well as your legs
and just relax
all right that was 500ab challenge
without any crunches let me know in the
comments below if your abs are on fire
be sure to attack to friends share this
workout with them challenge them to
complete this workout and let me know
your timing in the comments below don't
forget to check out my fitness app
called fear on the App Store download it
because you will stand a chance to win
amazing prizes subscribe to my youtube
channel give this video a thumbs up and
check out a lot more workout challenges
recipes as well as nutritional tips to
keep you motivated in your fitness
journey all the best